Привіт, любі шестикласники!
Рада вітати вас на уроці української мови
І з вами сьогодні я — Юлія Набок-Бабенко
[лунає музика]
Разом ми будемо вивчати числівник
як самостійну частину мови
Зокрема зупинимося на лексичному значенні,
граматичних ознаках та синтаксичній ролі
А також з'ясуємо, які числівники
бувають за будовою та значенням
Навіщо вивчати числівник?
Про це часто в мене запитують учні
Числівник варто вивчати, насамперед, тому щоб...
правильно говорити про гроші
Адже якщо, скажімо, вам потрібні гроші
чи ви хочете влаштуватися на роботу
і озвучити бажаний рівень зарплати,
то вам потрібно використати числівники
Навіщо вивчати числівник?
А якщо ви захочете придбати мобільний телефон?
І будете просити у батьків або ж
будете озвучувати своє бажання, то
потрібно сформулювати це числівником
Наприклад, айфон одинадцятий
[iPhone - прим. марка телефону]
Діапазон цін — від 769 до 1169 доларів
Обсяг пам'яті — 64 гігабайти
Розмір дисплею — від 42 до 44 міліметрів
Говорячи про це, ми вживаємо числівники
Навіщо вивчати числівник?
Щоб усюди встигати і все вчасно виконувати
Адже якщо ви правильно називатимете час,
то вас зрозуміють
Отож. Числа, числа, числа!
І там, де числа, там обов'язково будуть числівники
Числівник — це самостійна частина мови,
що означає кількість предметів або
порядок їх при лічбі
Відповідає на питання: "Котрий?", "Скільки?"
Наприклад:
Скільки? — Чотири
Котрий? — Четвертий
Залежно від значення виділяють
такі розряди числівників
Перший розряд — це кількісні
Всі кількісні числівники відповідають на питання: Скільки?
Наприклад,
вісім, восьмеро та інші
Порядкові відповідають на питання:
Котрий?
Наприклад, восьмий, перший, сотий,
сто другий та інші
Скільки?
Скільки, наприклад, коштує телефон,
який ви хочете придбати?
3845 — три тисячі вісімсот сорок п'ять
Щоб назвати ціну ми використали
кількісний числівник
Котрий телефон ви хочете придбати?
Якщо це, можливо, якась модель. Перша, десята... Одинадцята...
А, може, це ваш у житті перший, другий
чи третій телефон?
Також ми використовуємо числівники
Але цього разу порядкові
Як же змінюється числівник?
Якщо числівник кількісний, то він змінюється за відмінками
Наприклад, вісім — називний відмінок
Родовий — восьми
Давальний — восьми, вісьмом
Знахідний — вісім, восьми
Орудний — вісьма, вісьмома
Місцевий — на восьми, на вісьмох
Якщо це порядковий числівник, то він
змінюється за числами, родами та відмінками
Скажімо, восьмий — чоловічий рід.
Восьма — жіночий рід
Восьме — середній рід.
Восьмі — множина
Або ж за відмінками:
восьма — називний відмінок
Родовий — восьмої
Давальний — восьмій
Знахідний — восьму
Орудний — восьмою
Місцевий — на восьмій
та інші
Потренуймося
Якщо вам потрібно знайти числівник,
то першою підказкою для вас має бути питання
«Скільки?» або ж «Котрий?»
Тому якщо ви вагаєтеся, чи це числівник,
чи інша частина мови,
то вам слід поставити питання
Двійка
Питання: «Що?»
На питання «Що?» відповідає яка частина мови?
Іменник!
Тому слово «двійка» — це іменник
Подвійний.
Питання: «Який?»
На питання «Який?» відповідає...
прикметник!
Тому «подвійний» — це прикметник
Два.
Питання: «Скільки?»
На питання «Скільки?» відповідає
числівник
Подвоїти.
«Що зробити?»
Дієслово
Подвоєний.
«Який?»
Якщо утворено від дієслова «подвоїти»,
то «подвоєний» — це буде дієприкметник
Удвічі. «Як?» — удвічі.
Прислівник
По-друге. «Як?» — по-друге.
Теж прислівник
Таким чином, з переліку цих слів числівниками
є лише «два» і «другий»
Завдання
Спробуйте
Отож. Нумо перевіряти
До числівників належить: два, три, чотири, п'ять,
десять, двадцять, шістдесят, сто
Іменниками, утвореними від числівників,
є такі слова:
двійня, Трійця, чверть, п'ятірка, десяток,
двадцятка, сотня, сотник
Наступне завдання
Я нагадую, що кількісні числівники
відповідають на питання: «Скільки?»
Отож, шукаємо числівники, що
Скільки? Сім
А «сімка» на яке питання відповідає?
«Що?»
«Сімка» — це іменник
Одна сьома.
Питання: «Скільки?»
Усьоме.
Ні, це не числівник
Сотня.
Ні, питання: «Що?». Не числівник
Сто.
Скільки? — Сто. Числівник
Сотий.
«Котрий?». Це числівник, але порядковий
Одна п'ята.
«Скільки?». Числівник кількісний
По-третє.
Ні, не числівник
«Подвійний» — не числівник
«Другий» — числівник, але порядковий
«Троє» — числівник кількісний
«Двійка» — це іменник
«Четверо» і «двадцять» — це теж
числівники кількісні
Отож, якщо ви правильно виконали це завдання,
то мали виписати такі числівники
[вчителька перелічує слова з дошки]
Що ж можуть означати кількісні числівники?
Залежно від того, що означають, ми визначимо розряди за значенням кількісних числівників
Можуть означати цілі числа
Наприклад, три книги, два столи
Можуть означати дріб, дробові числа
Одна четверта торта, одна п'ята уроку
Можуть означати кількість предметів як одне ціле
Двоє робітників
Залежно від цього, є такі розряди
кількісних числівників
Отже, ми з вами з'ясували, що числівник
має два основні розряди
Це кількісні
Кількісні, нагадую, відповідають на питання: «Скільки?»
Та порядкові
Порядкові відповідають на питання: «Котрий?»
Кількісні, своєю чергою, поділяються
ще на чотири групи
Це цілі числа або власне-кількісні
Їх так і так називають
Цілі числа або власне-кількісні позначають кількість предметів у цілих одиницях
Наприклад: два, три, чотири, п'ять, шість, сім, вісім...
Це звичайні цілі числа
Або ж власне-кількісні
Наступний розряд — це дробові
Уже сама назва засвідчує, що це числівники,
які позначають не цілу частину
Тобто дріб
Прикладами дробових числівників є:
одна третя, одна сьома, п'ять десятих та інші
Третя група — це збірні
Збірні числівники позначають кількість предметів,
що сприймається як єдине неподільне ціле
Наприклад: троє, семеро, четверо, восьмеро,
десятеро, тридцятеро
І остання група — це неозначено-кількісні
Уже сама назва засвідчує, що
невизначена кількість
Ми не знаємо, скільки їх. До таких числівників
належать слова: мало, багато, достатньо
Тобто кількість невизначена, скільки ж саме
Кілька, декілька та інші
Звертаю вашу увагу, що збірні числівники можуть утворюватися не від усіх чисел
Збірні числівники утворюються лише від 2 до 20,
а також від 30
2-20 і 30
Лише від цих чисел ми можемо
утворити збірні числівники
Запам'ятайте, що збірні числівники вживаються
не з усіма іменниками,
а лише з певними категоріями слів
Зокрема, з назвами істот чоловічого роду
(четверо хлопців, двоє коней)
З іменниками, які належать до четвертої відміни
Нагадую, що до четвертої відміни належать іменники середнього роду
із закінченням -а/-я, при відмінюванні в яких з'являються суфікси -ат-/-ят-/-ен-
Наприклад: каченя, ягня...
Тому шестеро каченят, семеро ягнят
Також збірні числівники вживаються з іменниками, які є назвами неістот середнього роду
Троє імен, четверо вікон
Збірні числівники вживаються з іменниками, які існують тільки в множині
Так звані «множинні» іменники
Наприклад: троє ножиць, двоє дверей
І звертаю вашу увагу, що збірні числівники ніколи не вживаються з іменниками жіночого роду
Тому «двоє дівчат» — це не нормативна форма
«Двоє хлопців» — може бути
А якщо ви хочете позначити кількість,
то краще вжити «дві дівчини»
Потренуймося!
Визначте розряд кількісних числівників
Три
Погляньмо на нашу табличку, схемку
Три — кількісні — цілі числа
[вчителька показує таблицю]
Одна третя — кількісні — дробові
Троє — кількісні — збірні
[вчителька показує таблицю]
Мало — кількісні — неозначено-кількісні
Тому що ми не знаємо, скільки ж саме мало
Десятеро — кількісні — збірні
[вчителька показує таблицю]
«Десятий» є порядковим числівником
Дванадцять — кількісні — цілі числа
[вчителька показує таблицю]
Багато — кількісні — неозначено-кількісні
Сьомий  — це порядковий
Числівники за будовою поділяються
на такі розряди або ж групи
Прості, складні та складені
Якщо основа числівника складається лише
з одного кореня, то це простий числівник
Наприклад: два, п'ятий, сто та інші
Якщо основа числівника складається з двох і більше коренів, то це складний числівник
П'ятнадцять, шістдесят, сімдесят, вісімдесят та
всі інші, які йдуть після цих чисел
Це складні числівники
Складені числівники складаються
з двох та більше слів
Наприклад: шістдесят вісім, двісті шість та інші
Ваше завдання — розподіліть наведені числівники на 3 колонки за будовою
Нагадую: прості, складні, складені
7, 26, 17, 100, 8, 11, 2020, 60, 14, 3, 1000000, 31, 1, 80
[вчителька читає слова, що на дошці]
Якщо ви правильно виконали це завдання,
то має бути ось так
Прості: 7, 100, 8, 3, 1000000, 1
[вчителька читає слова, що на дошці]
Складні: 17, 11, 60, 14, 80
Складені — це два і більше слова.
Тому це всі інші: 26, 2020, 31
Яку ж синтаксичну роль виконує числівник?
Числівник може бути будь-яким членом речення
Погляньмо:
Двоє третього не чекають
Хто? Що?
«Двоє» — підмет. Числівник в ролі підмета
Кого не чекають?
«Третього». Числівник в ролі додатка
Світ широкий, а мати одна
Мати є одна.
«Одна» — це присудок
Тож числівник в ролі присудка
Вісім синів вдова мала, а дев'яту дочку
Вісім синів. «Вісім синів» — це додаток.
«Дев'яту» — означення
О десятій у нас заплановано зустріч
Коли запланована зустріч?
О десятій
«О десятій» — це обставина
Розгадаймо ребуси!
Смор-ОДИН-а.
Один, так? Смородина
Пі-ДВА-л
СТО-лиця
При-П'ЯТЬ
Ви-ТРИ-мка
Мі-СТО
Ві-ТРИ-на
СОРОК-а
Ві-СІМ-надцять
Що ж, час підбивати підсумки
За значенням числівники бувають
кількісні та порядкові
Кількісні, своєю чергою, поділяються на цілі числа (власне-кількісні), дробові
збірні та неозначено-кількісні
Порядкові відповідають на питання: «Котрий?»
За будовою числівники бувають
прості, складні та складені
Нагадую, якщо основа складається
лише з одного кореня — це прості
Якщо два і більше — це складні
Якщо два і більше слова, то це складені
Отож, незабаром пролунає дзвінок.
Час оголосити домашнє завдання
За підручником Олександри Глазової:
параграф 37, вправа 428
За підручником Світлани Єрмоленко:
параграф 54, вправа 452
За підручником братів Заболотних:
параграф 52, вправа 437
[лунає дзвінок]
Дякую за увагу. До нових уроків і нових зустрічей!